[موسيقى]
مباراه اكوادور والسنغال فاصله تماما في
تحديد من منهما يسقط الى الدور الثاني في
كاس العالم 2022 في قطر التعادل يمنح
مقعدا الاكوادور على حساب السنغال باعتبار
ان الاكوادور اربع نقاط والاستغلال ثلاث
نقاط يميز الفريق السنغالي بوجود حارس
المرمى ادوارد مندي في احسن حالاته ومعه
القلب الدفاع المحترف لي يضمن للدفاع السن
غالي جدارته بينما يتميز الفريق
الاكوادوري بالاداء الجماعي المنظمه بوجود
احد هداف البطوله فالنسيا برصيد ثلاث
اهداف اتوقع ان تكون كافه السنغال افضل في
ارض الملعب ولكن لان التعادل يكفي الفريق
الاكوادور للتاهل في فرصته اكبر قليلا
في المجموعه الثانيه انجلترا ويلز
الولايات المتحده
وايران مجموعه متشابكه اذا فازت انجلترا
تتاهل في المركز الاول ومعها الفائز من
ايران
والولايات المتحده او اذا تعادل تصعد معها
ايران اذا تعادل منتخب انجلترا يصعد اول
في المركز الاول ومعه
ايران او ومعه ايران اذا تعادلت مع امريكا
او يصعد معه امريكا ايضا ثانيه اذا فازت
على ايران لكن اذا تعادل منتخب انجلترا
وفاز ايران تحتلي ايران المركز الاول اذا
خسرت انجلترا بفارق اربع اهداف تصعد ويلز
بكل تاكيد ومعها الفائز من ايران
والولايات المتحده
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اتوقع ان تصعد هولندا واكوادور من
المجموعه الاولى انجلترا وايران من
المجموعه الثانيه
[تصفيق]